if you're watching this review of
episode 3 before watching the episode
then I'd highly recommend going back and
watching at first because I want to talk
a lot about the Battle of the stepstones
episode 3 opens with Damon Targaryen
assaulting the stepstones and trying to
prematurely end the war this scene is
surprisingly very productive because it
sets up a lot of different developments
that will be important later on like
Damon being kind of careless towards his
soldiers the geography of the
battlefield in the asset of the caves
and the big arsenal of archers that can
put a lot of pressure on a dragon I
think it's a perfect idea to have this
set piece Grant the antagonist with
something that inherently counters
dragons because nerfing dragons brings
down Damon's side to actually have to
fight for their Victory instead of the
easily incinerating everyone this was
something that I was curious about how
they were going to handle because just
having the dragons wiping out a whole
Army wouldn't have enough conflict but
coming up with natural ways to limit
them is good writing this was a major
issue in season 8 where the supposed
limit of scorpions were relatively
useless against drogon despite them
being set up as very lethal against
rhaegal so in that particular battle
there was really no suspense because
Daenerys was just wiping the floor with
the Enemy here in House of the Dragon
Damon has to get his hands dirty and
risk his life because he can't depend on
caraxi's which before getting into that
bit of action the prior scene in which
he gets the letter from his brother
really establishes Matt Smith as a
perfect choice for Damon's Targaryen him
smiling through his annoyance with
viserys's decision to send to Aid throws
the audience for a minor Loop because
he's not actually smiling and relieved
that he's getting help there's just so
much to read into for this quick
expression and it's really intriguing
this moment was also made even better
because of how much pressure was put
onto viserys to lend aided Daemon and
the valerians so all this turmoil just
for Damon to be an absolute Chad and
deny the backup to instead prove himself
was a legendary character building
moment he doesn't want to be relying on
his brother and live in his shadow but
instead wants to become his own dragon
this major emphasis on character is so
relieving because you don't want to just
have a battle be pure spectacle that's
why to me this one scene of Damon's rush
to get to the crab feeder was so amazing
now there are certain aspects that I've
seen criticize like Damon having plot
armor in relation to not getting hit by
arrows but the fact that he is doing a
Full Tilt Sprint like Tom Cruise and is
occasionally taking cover counters The
Barrage of arrows a bit to a degree it
can be a little frustrating but in
comparison to the battle the bastards as
an example where Jon Snow survives like
a dozen aerostorms while not doing
anything I'd much prefer the battle of
the stepsons in that regard because at
least Damon is making an effort to avoid
the arrows then when he gets bogged down
by a bunch of pirates and loses his
speed that's when he gets hit so any
fear that Damon had plot armor in this
moment for me vanished because at least
the man is getting injured and on that
point I love that they allowed Daemon to
get injured because it proves that what
he was doing was really dangerous though
us it doesn't compromise and make any
threats in the show a joke this also
coincides with character building
because he's risking everything to prove
himself and it showcases how strong
Daemon is because he's continuing to
fight with his injuries that's the thing
with arrow hits you can easily make them
non-lethal and have your hero try John
so I don't know why it didn't happen at
least once in the battle of the bastards
going into the action side of things for
this entire battle I was a little
annoyed with the editing and how quickly
cut and drawing it all felt to a degree
battles need this aspect but not almost
a hundred percent of it this would annoy
me a lot more if it wasn't for the main
focus being on Damon getting to the crab
feeder but in terms of the execution of
the chaotic action the creators
essentially nailed down that aspect in
Game of Thrones so they are still doing
it really well here a cool little detail
in the behind the scenes was that they
made big plastic maces and filled them
with blood that would explode blood all
over people when they got hit that was
pretty interesting and it made for great
shots of people getting demolished
one other small critique was that the
VFX at times didn't look as good as
usual the dragons aren't the culprit
here and they've gotten them down to a t
but basic things like blood hits and
squirts looked off generally it's pretty
easy to tell when blood is fake because
VFX blood normally looks two-dimensional
and doesn't have the same minor light
diffractions that go on in blood since
it's a liquid this is also made even
more noticeable since they use real
blood effects in some shots even earlier
on in the episode where Rainier is
stabbing the boar to death it looks like
her face is getting spray painted now I
don't know if this was a budgetary issue
and they were simply running out of
money from how expensive the episode was
or if this was just an oversight but at
the end of the day this isn't a big
issue and it's kind of a nitpick however
it did bother me a tiny bit and it
wasn't just the blood for the final
moment of Damon dragging out the crap
Peter's corpse I've seen people say that
it was anti-climatic but honestly the
anti-climatic part for me wasn't that
Daemon killed the crap eater off screen
who innovative self probably couldn't
fight but the fact that the battle was
essentially just starting and it ends
really quickly going back to the fact
that there was a lot of chaotic action I
wish we got some longer takes of
cordless valerion shredding through
people to make the battle more
satisfying and rewarding because as it
stands the meat of the battle lasts
about two minutes not including the
Damon Rush which again is the main draw
of this scene so I feel like the
unsatisfying feeling some people may
feel stems from the fact of the short
battle instead of the outcome of the
crab feeder because to me just because
we can't see his death doesn't make that
part any worse since I've talked a lot
about the Battle of the stepstones I'll
just touch on some of the highlights of
the rest of the episode and I also won't
bog down this review with how sexy sir
Chris and Cole's attempts a word to
seduce renera with a sweet campfire
getaway for the king's hunts initially I
was a little underwhelmed by this entire
40 minute portion of the episode but it
was like a snowball rolling down a hill
as it gets bigger the episode starts out
at actually catching us up as to what
happened in the last three years and
provides updates but the second the
episode is done with that the conflict
Sparks and makes everything really
interesting this is primarily in the
form of viscera slowly getting more
drunk as the day goes on it really
amplifies his struggles as a king and it
really spices up every Dynamic that
would otherwise be a little dull Patty
constadon is really giving an
outstanding performance and the singular
moment of Ottawa Hightower suggesting
that we're near a Mary aegon was
hilarious now it feels a little out of
character for Otto Hightower to say this
because of how stupid it was in the
moment but it does spawn a great line
for viserys
suffocated by all this [ __ ] polity
King it's also ironic that the one
person that is genuinely trying to give
him good advice is Lionel strong because
besides him this poor guy is just
getting bombarded by everyone and I
think they did a magnificent job this
episode in showing his struggles I love
how he isn't a perfect character and
regularly makes mistakes something that
essentially haunts him because
prematurely naming renura as his Heir
before having a male child May
inadvertently start a war in the future
making decisions as the king is
extremely important and any minor
mistakes he makes exponentially affects
the realm as a whole which is pretty
much showcased to the stepstone's
conflict despite that being a not so
minor mistake and get it minor eh I've
seen some people dislike viserys for
making so many mistakes or him just
being stupid at times but internally
flawed characters to me are inherently
interesting because they breed so much
conflict from their actions like Robert
Baratheon was an extremely flawed
character and he was a fan fan favorite
among other reasons too and not only is
viserys being pressured by all of this
conflict but he's also literally falling
apart this poor guy isn't catching any
breaks which I'm also kind of curious
how the cut is doing on his back I feel
like they're going to reveal around
episode 5 or something and half his back
is going to be black it also may just be
me but I feel like through Paddy
considine's performance he's subtly
showing he's holding back pain in some
scenes I feel like he's in constant
anguish from his back because inevitably
his death is going to come from the
throne which will be really poetic being
King is what will kill faceres almost as
if the throne rejects him for not being
a good ruler but looking at one more
scene for viserys his monologue by the
bonfire was so mesmerizing even when
this man is drunk he is spitting some
great lines like what is the power of a
dragon next to the power of a prophecy
and I thought reneros my way out of my
abyss of grief and regret so some good
lines are making their way into the show
slowly and relax when saying the
dialogue isn't good because it is good
but the scene acts as an emotional
climax for viserys as he reveals having
visions of aegon and his obsession of
having a boy is what killed renira's
mother the moment he actually questions
himself as if he's been making mistakes
really hit me hard because the second
you come to that realization it's over
second guessing himself that's the end
for him
for the clever little [ __ ]
for everyone
so to me this scene was a definite
standout next to Damon's rush and out of
the entirety of the king's hunt I
initially had one critique which is now
gone but it felt pretty hypocritical at
the time for near and not wanting to
marry anyone because in the episode
prior she was very understanding of her
father marrying again and the overall
tradition of marrying and getting more
power thus furthering your line but in
later scenes back in King's Landing they
revealed the extra layer of Vernier
being troubled by the fact that she
wouldn't become Queen anymore and will
also be losing her Valley by marrying
someone to me it went from a generic
father and daughter conundrum back to
the complex drama of medieval times it's
also nice that they make visares really
kind to his daughter and his approval
for her to marry at her own pace and
choosing it's really his main redeeming
quality and is very wholesome God I just
love their Dynamic and it makes me sad
that their time is fleeting since
they're doing so many time jumps but
yeah overall episode 3 was very good and
I'm happy to see that the action was
well executed despite there being some
hiccups but I don't want to be overly
critical because it wasn't really that
long and the actual main moment of the
battle was still incredible thank you
for watching and let me know what you
thought about episode 3 of House of the
Dragon